[Music]
advanced technology and close calls
highlight what has been released from a
pentagon report on ufos
the executive summary was made public
today that's right well there are some
things already known about what is and
what is not included george knapp of
mystery wire
is here to tell us more hey george good
to see both of you
this is the long-awaited report here
compiled by the
uap task force as directed by congress
released to the public late on a friday
afternoon
and it consisted of a whopping nine
pages two of those pages are indexes
and one is a cover page so there wasn't
much there there but
anyone who's been paying attention would
have known this report was never going
to be a tell-all expose
an admission that space aliens are among
us that the roswell crash happened or
that
spaceships have been stashed out near
area 51. the reality is
there were two reports one was a longer
classified version given only to
congress
containing sensitive materials that the
public may never see
and then the shorter less definitive
summary for the public right here
the report acknowledges the obvious
there could be many explanations
for the cases examined by the military
the report included 144 total cases
80 of those detected on multiple sensors
there were 11 incidents where american
warplanes had near mid-air collisions
with the unknown objects
there were 18 cases where the objects
exhibited unusual flake characteristics
for the most report that makes the case
that we really do not know
how to categorize these objects that we
lack information
and mostly that we lack the ability to
ever figure them out that what we need
are better sensors
a free exchange of information and less
stigma for service members
to report these things late today we got
the first comments from former nevada
senator harry reid
who got the ball rolling on ufo studies
back in two thousand
seven senator so it's finally out
an underwhelming nine pages at least the
public version of the report
what's your initial impressions well the
government has acknowledged that they
don't know what these
unidentified flying objects are and so
when i started talking about this years
ago people made fun of me and
even my own staff thought it was crazy
and
talking about it but in hindsight
i'm glad i did certainly we now
know that there have been they have 142
signings we know there have been more
than that
but it's something that as far as i'm
concerned this is a preliminary report
and i mean preliminary there needs to be
a tremendous amount of government
resources put into this so we better
understand it so
so it's not some kind of a fringe
part of what government's doing they've
got to dive into this because
we and the american people are entitled
to know what the hell is going on
one possible outcome from this report
could be congressional hearings into the
ufo mystery there were two such hearings
back in the 60s but since then
ufos have been considered too wacky for
congress to touch
george and your experience in this field
how big of a step toward disclosure is
this report
it's not really disclosure it's one step
toward disclosure what it is
is sort of a form of confirmation that
we actually have a legitimate mystery in
here
this report essentially makes the case
that we need a permanent ongoing study
and if we're ever going to figure this
out we've got to assign it to someone
establish a framework for that make it
easier for our military members
to report it and then provide some money
to dig into it and figure it out
certainly wow and george this is all
really interesting you said that this is
a really big day where do we go from
here what's the next step
well i think we need to put some money
into it establish a permanent study but
already what's happened is a remarkable
change
that i never saw thought i would see in
my lifetime all these years of chasing
this crazy mystery
uh the the congress has admitted it's a
legitimate mystery it deserves our
attention
they called for the uap task force to be
created they created it
a report was put together by the
pentagon the media is interested they're
covering it that not all of us are
totally crazed and out of our minds and
that it's a legitimate subject of
inquiry that's a remarkable change in
just a short period of time
and i can't wait to see what happens
next all right well i bet you've got a
lot more calls to your radio show in
those overnight hours right
yeah and all day long yeah all day long
all day long
all right anything where you'd like to
add on it so i'm just i'm really excited
about it it's an exciting time that as i
said i didn't think i'd see
and there's so much more outside this
very thin realm that was dug into by the
task force
of military encounters there's so many
more cases that have not been
investigated
and so and there's a great history this
only looked at cases from the tic tac
on 2004 through 2021. this has
a 74-year history in the modern era and
maybe thousands of years more than that
to look into
wow fascinating stuff yeah it really is
thank you so much for being here george
we greatly appreciate that